all right let's consult a map here's
Germany Morocco
and Fantasyland
but beyond Walt Disney World's borders
you find a larger boundary the central
Florida tourism oversight District
that's been at the center of a feud
between Disney and Governor Ron DeSantis
there's a new share
strict started way before the DeSantis
Disney War it explains something about
the history of Florida and the lost city
of Epcot it will be a community of
tomorrow that will never be completed
and most importantly why Disney World Is
Here
and isn't moving anytime soon
this isn't Disney World but Disneyland
and the key thing is not the park but
the surroundings
antonian Heim a 40-minute drive from Los
Angeles
and opened in 1955. in an internal
publication Disney showed its belief
that the site provided sufficient land
for present and future growth
period photos show the area didn't start
as densely developed as it is today
but this 1965 map shows how quickly
things changed everything from schools
to shopping centers limited Disneyland's
control over its future
Walt Disney needed more and he wanted to
get more from a new park
[Music]
he wanted his new park to be on the East
Coast he needed a lot of land so dense
urban areas were out he didn't want cold
that narrowed things down to Florida he
also didn't want to compete with the
ocean so he skipped Coastal locations
when flying over Orlando he saw I-4 I-95
in the Sunshine State Parkway
that clinched it locals started to
notice big land deals being made by
mystery companies soon Floridians began
to suspect their mystery industry was
Disney
[Music]
the size was immense here's the size of
Disneyland if it were in Florida and
here is the land they bought for Disney
World as it is today even after some
land was sold off shortly after the land
story broke Disney held a press
conference with Governor Hayden Burns
and brother Roy Disney to discuss the
plants
will bring a new world of entertainment
pleasure and economic development to the
State of Florida Walt Disney let's break
down this next Walt Disney quote after
you've done something you
see uh with the experience and all of
that what you might do he was starting
from scratch Disney wanted to get right
what he missed in Anaheim I've taken a
look at the land this morning I say we
are starting from scratch
Delane needed a lot of work drainage
work development everything just look at
this 1962 map of the area
there were some orange groves on the
land but this symbol means swamp the
area is called the Reedy Creek swamp but
we have many things in mind that to make
this unique and different than
Disneyland Disney also had greater
Ambitions for the land that he would
only reveal later on
here in Florida we have something
special we've never enjoyed at
Disneyland there's enough land here to
hold all of the ideas and plans we could
possibly imagine to persuade Florida's
government to support the project Disney
released concept art like this that
showed way more than a theme park like a
giant industrial complex and a
constantly evolving city of 30
000 people Epcot an experimental
prototype community of tomorrow
all these buried activities around the
Disney World
tied together by a high-speed rapid
transit system running almost the full
length of the property it will never
cease to be a living blueprint of the
future
where people actually live a life they
can't find anywhere else in the world
but Disney didn't want to wait for
permits for every sewer drain and light
post in his city of tomorrow
to have complete dominion over the land
he bought he needed political control
not just a title
he needed a kingdom
Special Districts are common tens of
thousands of them exist across the
United States
for example the famous retirement
community The Villages just north of
Disney uses them these led residents
vote on a board which then establishes
policies that can raise taxes build
stuff or fund Public Safety departments
this can happen across Municipal
boundaries county lines or other
traditional boundaries Disney wanted a
super power version of this with Disney
staff as the sole voting residence
inside it they would be able to vote
themselves in and make their own rules
the Disney World land is split between
orange and Osceola counties it also
includes what planning documents list as
jurisdictions of the city of Bay Lake
unincorporated areas and the City of
Lake Buena Vista all of which were
created for and are largely controlled
by Disney they had multiple points of
Leverage to get this I
more people will talk about and come to
look at
than any other area in the world all
these plans meant promise of economic
development for a relatively sleepy area
that whisperance at least a 50 percent
and possibly a hundred percent increase
in tourism in the State of Florida
Disney could also threaten to pursue
alternate sites in Northern California
in Mineral King they had a parallel
proposal to build a ski complex that was
closer to Anaheim and less swampy it
ended up serving as a taunt to Florida
the result was clear in the same issue
of Disney's internal magazine in which
they announced the biggest surprise of
the decade Florida's VIPs were already
flying out to begin working on Project
problems
other places didn't Grant big powers
like Florida there was no ski resort in
Mineral King because the Sierra Club
fought it and the state never approved
it
all that is why Disney World is here
in May 1967 the Reedy Creek improvement
district was chartered as an entity that
could regulate across counties like its
own government it could control sewage
generation of Power by nuclear fission
airport facilities railroads and
construction and Disney used its powers
the company created an underground
tunnel system for their utilities called
utilidors each tunnel had spots for
ventilation water and transportation
they built the monorail and they created
their own Lake the Seven Seas Lagoon so
the parking lot wouldn't sit too close
to the castle they did it all because
they could in 1966 Walt Disney died in
Los Angeles the city part of his Disney
World dream mostly died with him despite
some gestures toward building it Epcot
became a part of the theme park in 1982
but it was not a city the district's
comprehensive 10-year plan shows how far
the Disney Dream has drifted from Epcot
undeveloped land is labeled green for
conservation not as the foundation for
some future city mass transportation
consists of buses in the monorail line
rather than the intricate Transit
Network that Disney envisioned Disney
has massive population staying in its
many hotels but when you look at a map
of permanent residential addresses in
the district you see eight here and nine
here it's projected to be about 43
people by 2027.
Disney ensured that later residential
developments didn't change things
development of Disney's imagineered
small town Celebration Florida began on
the district in the 1990s but it was
de-annexed from Reedy Creek the same
happened for the Disney owned Plantation
Park Condos in Little Lake Bryant being
cut out of the district means no voting
for the board all of this was just
background until the feud
welcome to the Walt Disney company's
annual meeting of shareholders I called
Governor DeSantis this morning to
express our disappointment and concern
Disney CEO called to protest Florida's
don't say Gala which restricts classroom
instruction about sexual orientation
We Believe being joined at the hip with
this one california-based company was
not something that was justifiable or
sustainable and promised the corporate
Kingdom finally comes to an end but the
taunting continued
operatically as they were someone even
said like maybe you need another state
prison who knows I mean I just think
that the the possibilities are are are
endless still the state would struggle
to actually dissolve the district the
charter gives the district the power to
finance the projects and activities of
the district through bonds if the
district disappeared hundreds of
millions in bond debt would probably
flow to taxpayers in Orange and Osceola
counties and on the other side Disney
has already made noise about a 17
billion dollar Disney World expansion in
the end Disney's district has had a name
change and board composition and process
May slightly change but Germany and
Morocco aren't going anywhere the
kingdom will probably stay a kingdom
[Music]